And now the old scout master.
Okay, can I ask this question then?
Yes, sir,
What is the penguins in the desert?
Two penguins are in a canoe in the desert and the one in the front looks to the one
in the back and he says: where's your paddle?
And the penguin in the back says: yeah, it sure does.
Yeah,
Yeah, exactly
What.
Yeah, I even wrote that one down. I can't get it.
Okay, so they're in a canoe in the desert.
Now, what's in the desert
Sand?
What are paddles made out of
Wood?
The first penguin says: where's your paddle?
The second penguin says: yeah, it sure does.
Yeah, I'm thick on that one.
Where's?
W-H-E-R-E- apostrophe S, and W-E-A-R-S.
Where's,
As in, where's out,
Where's out?
Okay,
Where's your paddle?
Where's out?
Yep, it sure does.
So how long has that one been floating out there?
A long time,
Way too long,
Way, way too long.
I've had to explain it a number of times.
Here's three more times.
Yeah, exactly,
I've been waiting for you because you've run through it a couple of times
in the podcast and you're like: good, what's the answer?
What's the answer?
Well, now you know you're in the secret group of people.
Now I know
I won't tell anybody,
No, nor will I tell the joke?
No, it'll be on the podcast next week.
Hey, this is podcast 113, 113..
Welcome back to this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and see who has been in touch.
Woodhunter left a nice comment and review on iTunes-
Another five-star review.
He said: excellent podcast with a wise speaker.
This is a podcast that I look forward to listening to every week
and one that I keep each edition of
so I can listen to them again and again.
Well, thanks very much.
That's very kind,
Brett Niemeyer. he said: thank you for the podcast.
It really helps broaden my perspective as a Scoutmaster
in serving our Scouts, our fellow Scouters
and other volunteers in our troop district and council.
Thanks so much, Brett, and thanks for being in touch.
Lou Rinaldo, who is an assistant Scoutmaster
with Troop 628 in the Glaciers Edge Council in Wisconsin,
wrote in and said: I really appreciate your work.
Are the podcasts available for a Zoom on the Zoom Marketplace?
And Lou notes: a Scout is thrifty.
I got my Zoom used.
Well, Lou, thank you for being in touch.
I'm glad you're enjoying the podcast
And I have, at your prompting, made the podcast
available on the Zoom Marketplace.
And you know, it's an untapped part of the market.
I didn't realize that I wasn't on there,
So now the podcast is available to the two or three
dozen Zoom users that are left in the world.
Blaze Vitale over on Google Plus
sent this report.
Blaze participated in one of our Scoutmaster
panel discussions recently.
He said our Troop had a great meeting today.
using a suggestion in a podcast,
I had the boys read pages 36 through 39
of the Scout manual.
Then I stepped back and they made their own patrols.
The process was somewhat chaotic
but the boys seemed reasonably happy
with their decision.
Get the boys to read the book
and then do what's in the book.
How about that?
Good for you, Blaze.
I'm glad to hear things are going well.
Darren Cranford over on Google Plus said
he's listening to the Scoutmaster podcast
on Scouts Canada.
That was a couple, three podcasts ago.
He said there must be something wrong
with Harry Snyder's mic
because he sounds awfully funny. eh,
We did have a little cultural exchange
of accents on the podcast
that we dedicated to Scouts Canada,
So do go and listen.
In this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast
we're very happy to present you
with the April edition of the Scoutmaster
panel discussion.
We had a great guest
and hopefully you will find the information useful.
So let's get started, shall we?
Hey, it's time for another
Scoutmaster panel discussion.
This week we got two out of three,
which ain't bad, they tell me,
Those two out of three. we have
Larry Geiger down in Vieira, Florida.
How you doing, Larry?
Good Good evening, Clark.
And we've got Tom Gillard
in Tallahoma, Tennessee.
Tom,
Hey, Clark, how are you?
I am doing well.
And our third musketeer, Walter,
is off on a jet plane somewhere.
He's doing college tours with one of his boys, isn't he?
Yes,
That's what I heard.
You know who just showed up on Skype?
Hi there,
Walter's in the airport.
Hey, Walter,
Yes,
I'll sign off.
Hey, Walter,
I was going to tell you something. that happened,
though, when we were flying back from,
or getting on the plane to come back from, Hawaii.
We got on the plane and it started raining,
and I could. it was raining,
but I could see rain on the window of the airplane,
but not on the tarmac,
And I thought:
and Conan, does the rain fall mainly on the plane?
Well, I think I've got to get in line.
We'll talk to you soon.
Okay,
Bye,
You guys have a good talk,
Right?
Okay
Bye,
One of the things that I have had several questions about
over the past few weeks
is talking about Meribadge, blue cards,
And I guess if you want to be really doctrinaire
and official about it,
this is the application for a Meribadge
And the first step with that.
when a boy gets a blue card,
he brings it to the unit leader for a signature.
and what in the world is the unit leader
doing? sign in that?
Why does the unit leader need to sign
an application for a Meribadge?
I think it's just so you can see
what's being worked on
And it's just sort of the keep you in the loop
and then I can look for a counselor
if they have any problems.
I agree with all that Tom said for sure.
I guess what I wanted to say is that
in scouting
those kinds of times are designed to facilitate
non-confrontational interaction
between the adult and the scout.
It's part of the adult relationship.
So Scoutmaster conferences,
signing blue cards,
boards of review, things like that
kind of institutionalizes the relationship.
It's part of the conversation.
So let's say, John, he's a second class,
He decides to work on his forestry Meribadge.
He gets a blue card.
Scoutmaster says why forestry?
And he says he's curious about that
And then he says: well,
how are you doing on your second class rank?
And the scout says: good,
Anyway, I only have two more requirements.
I'm working on some first class stuff.
Scoutmaster signs a blue card,
sends a scout on his way.
So conversation happened,
a relationship.
I got another example here.
Scoutmaster: hi, Freddie,
So I see you're interested in starting another Meribadge.
Question: how are you doing on the other 11
you signed up for?
How did you pick this Meribadge?
Have you contacted
one of the other 11 Meribadge counselors? yet
How are you doing on getting to first class?
And then the question:
well, do you want to hold off starting another
before you finish a couple of other ones?
Maybe we could talk about
finishing something
one thing before we start another one.
So there's a piece of conversation.
you know things like that
And so you know.
when he's done,
Freddie says: well, I want to start it.
then he signs it.
And some people are going: well, why would you sign it?
Well, that's not the point.
The point is they had the conversation.
The point is that they interacted.
So, just like with the Scoutmaster conference,
it's not there to pass the scout,
it's there to facilitate the conversation,
to facilitate the interaction.
So I don't know.
I think that's really important that we do that.
By the way, Freddie's a real scout.
That's not his name
and he's not in the troop anymore.
but you know, I think he ended up
starting 16 merit badges
and I think he finished one.
but that's about it.
I ran across some leaders
at a function
that troop policy was
they would not sign
any blue cards.
They would not accept blue cards
if the scout had
X number of open merit badges already.
And I piped up
and said: you can't do that.
And they go. well, that's troop policy,
That's what we've been doing.
I said, okay,
Because I wasn't about to
change that
You weren't going to have a bear in that fight.
No, I don't think so.
Well, I think it's important to think about that.
Here's what I hear.
is that a lot of times,
unit leaders- and we're mostly
talking to Scoutmasters,
but I want to include everybody
as a team coach and things like that-
They think that
the signing
the merit application
for a merit badge,
where it says that I approve
of this,
means that they need to vet
the whole situation
and tell a scout
whether or not he can
do a particular merit badge,
Maybe because of his age, maybe because
of his rank or something like that.
That's what I'm hearing from you guys, though
You don't think that that's the right way to go.
Well, if a scout came to me and said
I'm going to start what, is it life saving?
The first question I was asked:
do you have first aid merit badges?
He says no.
I'd say, well, I guess I can sign this,
but there's no reason to because
you got to get first aid first.
There's two or three where you got to have one
before the other,
But other than that, no,
There's no reason to not sign it.
I'm pretty clear on that,
And you'd advise him,
You talk to him,
You give him the benefit of your experience,
but you wouldn't deny him the opportunity
to go ahead and give a shot at that merit badge.
No, I've never not
signed one that I
can think of.
There's merit badge universities.
There's the day
they're going to spend at the local museum
working on a particular merit badge,
or something like that.
There's lots of group
opportunities,
but there's also the individual
opportunities.
Two or three scouts may
run down a counselor
and decide to do the merit badge together,
And so
that would be one of the functions
of our signing the blue card would be
to make sure that
the scout is going to a registered counselor.
Yes,
Check out who they're going to go see
and know who that is
And then encourage them
to take another scout or two with them
if they want to.
If the scout wants the merit badge
and they need a mom
or another scout or somebody there,
Yeah, we typically-
a lot of ours- have ended up
meeting out over at the library
just to have a
public venue
for something like that
And mom or dad
is looking around
or something They're close by.
but this one kid
wants to do this merit badge
and nobody else wants to.
And I think let me jump in
and say that
for those who may be listening
who aren't familiar,
the way that a merit badge counselor
relates to a scout
is according to
the BSA's youth protection policies.
So that means there's no
meeting.
The scout either has a parent
or a buddy with him
or they're in a public place
or you know,
I usually take the opportunity
when I'm signing a blue card
to quiz a scout
about those protection policies
and ask him
when he plans on meeting with the person
and who will be there
and things like that,
And that doesn't happen all that often.
usually it's somebody within the troop.
So I kind of look at this whole process,
you know,
as merit badge counselors, meeting with the scout,
scoutmaster conferences, blue card signatures,
service hour,
approval signatures.
you know all those kind of things are designed
to facilitate communication
and the association with adults
method.
And yet, kind of
it's not that we don't want to talk to the
scouts at other times, but there are
just like at work. you know we have
annual or biannual evaluations.
there's a certain
institutionalized communication
between
you know, two parties. we have the same thing in
scouting
And it's mostly
for that purpose
and not for approvals and stuff.
It's a really
actually it's a great opportunity because,
like in the scenario you described, Larry
Boy wants to do forestry merit badge.
why are you interested in forestry merit
badge? well, I, you know, saw
something on TV or I read a book
or, and I just
got really interested in it as well.
is there, you know? is there anything else
about it that interests you? do you know
that requirement,
that second-class requirement where you have
to know 10 plants and animals? do you
have you ever looked at that?
can you help instruct something like that?
and then the other thing is,
I think it's really good when the
advancement chair gives the scout his
portion of the blue card
and then eventually the scout gets,
gets the card,
the merit badge card, because I have
had scouts
at Eagle time who have had
their
rear-end saved because
they had some documentation
like those cards
signed
by the appropriate people and
something got lost along the way,
even perhaps in the advancement
records in the troops. so
not real common, but
two or three times at least. the merit
badge card has been like: wait a minute,
open their notebook. you know, I tell
the scouts, get a,
get a notebook and buy those things
for baseball cards
and all the scout cards fit in
those slots, they're about the same size.
and scouts pulled out and said right here,
here's my card signed by Mr
Geiger and you know
the chairman, and
and everybody goes, oh, no problem,
we have patrol advisors
who are the adults that
put, they control
the computer. so the scouts
give them their books and
and they put stuff into troop master
through that and they they're the ones
that
initially get the,
the blue card, or.
or they come to me and I signed off that,
yes, it's complete,
go give it to Mr so and so,
go give it to your patrol advisor
and he will enter it into the into the computer
for you. so off they go,
they keep their part, but the,
the unit portion,
goes into their file folder in the,
in the file cabinet.
same same principle, that way
that if they lose them
we still got a record,
if we, if the counselor, doesn't have
their sauce, I think,
increasingly, as we
have
put these things into databases and everything,
that it's increasingly
easier to follow that trail. but that
little piece of paper can come in handy,
right, and and then, when the, when the
scout turns 18, you,
you pull his file folder and hand it
all of this paper.
yeah, that's what, that's what we do. if we,
if a scout leaves in such a way- we know,
you know,
like, oh, this is when he's moving on, we
give him his, his stuff.
occasionally they just disappear, but
we have limited space, so we need
to get rid of it fairly quick,
okay,
so joining us for the scout master
panel discussion is Walter Torres,
and Walter is up in Chicago,
is that right? Walter? yes, just outside the
city. and Walter, it has
been an assistant scout master
for a number of years. what's going to happen
in May, Walter? um, I get
promoted, yeah, yeah,
I- scout master as of May.
he's a senior scout master
of five years is retiring.
so you've been through the whole
program with three
signs. is that right? that
right? I have 20 year old
twins right now and
my youngest is 16. all three boys
and I started
my adult career in scouts when the
older, when the twins, were tiger cubs-
wow, yeah. so I was a tiger cub
coach
and committee chair and then when they
we blows, I was we blows den leader
and then I was,
uh, assistant scout master when
the older boys crossed over and I was
den leader- we blows den leader again
for my youngest son. that's, that's a long
time in cubs. man, yeah, it is.
it really is.
that's pretty intense.
well, god bless you for doing it.
so what can we help you with this
evening? well, our unit has
sort of been traditionally adult
led, but, um, as of
May, when I'm going to
sort of be scout master, I'm hoping to
sort of move things around
and, um, I've got quite a
few of the committee behind it and
the committee chair is absolutely behind
it. in fact, I've met, I've known him,
since our, our youngest, have been in cub
scouts. so, okay, that's
a long history there.
so one of the things that that was
interesting to me was reading these
older books, was these patrol activities,
patrol hikes, patrol camps,
patrol camps and senior and
service projects and so forth.
but then I've got the new
guide to safe scouting,
January 12, and it describes,
uh, of course, to the
to deep leadership, uh,
21 year old, required trips
and outings. and then it says-
quote: there are a few instances,
such as patrol activities,
when the presence of adult
leaders are not required.
an adult leadership may be limited
to training and guidance of
the patrol leadership.
and then
it goes on with the proper training, guidance,
approval of troop leaders.
the patrol can conduct day hikes
and service projects.
so
I guess there's two parts of this.
what is there a real
list of approved, quote, unquote
patrol activities? and
what happened to the patrol camping?
I'll do my best to answer.
the part that you read from the guide to safe scouting
also notes that,
uh, while
patrols can conduct
day hikes and service projects,
appropriate adult leadership must be present for all
overnight scouting activities.
and, um,
that is actually,
I think that is fairly new,
I would say within the past five or six years.
does that ring a bell with you guys
in my background? we,
we basically did anything that we wanted
to do.
we did have patrol camp
hikes, patrol fundraisers.
we were all over the community
on our bikes with wagons.
um, you know, we had
patrol bike hikes.
we did our hiking merit
badges alone or
with a patrol,
barely with an adult.
but since coming back to scouting
in 87 I
haven't had
any experience with
patrol camping,
as we were saying earlier.
it just doesn't
seem to come up. the guys
haven't really
requested it or
they've never said, oh, what's that all about?
and I remember
doing that as a kid also.
we would be all over the
place. but, um, my patrols
recently have done
bike hikes as a patrol.
they just
plan it and go
draw a map.
so there's been some patrol
activity
and I would encourage that.
you know what you just said.
the patrol
activity is one thing,
but they have to get there
and they have to get back.
so there's always an adult
usually nearby.
somehow.
in viera there's
a lot of kids that are relatively
close by.
they ride their bikes to somebody's
house and then go on a 5 mile
bike hike
and they just one saturday
meet at 9am and off they go
and they come back.
but they tend to do that
kind of stuff in our community
on their own also.
they get on their bike and ride to the
sports fairly common in
viera,
other parts of florida
maybe not so much.
so I think there's two answers to
one part of this question.
one is that there is
some specific guidance
from the guide to safe scouting about
adults being present on overnight
scouting activities,
sounds like it.
and the other one is that in
our experience- and I will agree,
Larry and Tom,
in our experience there's not
a whole lot of opportunity
at present for patrols
just to get together and go on a camp
out or something. how long ago,
Larry, for you as a
youth in scouting- 40 years,
30 years
maybe,
alright, so at least 40,
maybe, at least 40
maybe. so you go back
and things were.
things were a little bit different.
it was before the age of the automobile
and the airplane,
I'm sorry.
well, my mom didn't drive until I was
14,
12, I don't know.
so when I was a kid
we went everywhere on our bicycles
and my guess is that all your pals
and the guys that were in your patrol
were within reach of you by bicycle.
oh yeah,
the guys that are in our troops
now. that's just kind of.
there's kind of like a physical
impossibility
for them to be able to get on
a bike and go visit their patrol.
in big
school districts they can be
a 15-20 minute
drive apart.
well, it's kind of cliche,
but it was a different time. back then
people, there weren't as many cars
on the streets
and
right now I wouldn't put my
kid out on some of these streets for anything.
they would get run over.
there's kind of like those two answers.
there's a
guide to safe scouting,
for overnight
scouting events, and then we also need to be
thinking about
just the kind of
logistical challenges that there are.
hey, Walter, are we
helping any? I mean, I
guess the next
going with it is the idea of
the boys sort of venturing out.
one of Clark's podcast
he talked about
his guys going out on a camp, out
camping together on Friday
and then Saturday
marching off on their own some distance away,
and then the adults
sort of dropping in a couple of times during the day
just to make sure
the mayhem and the bloodshed was at a minimum.
and
that's pretty much what I was really hoping to do.
I would highly
encourage that
type of activity. when we camp
we don't go to
KOAs or
a lot of times even scout camps.
we go basically
into wilderness. there's no bathroom, there's no,
you know, it's a,
a fire ring and a couple picnic tables,
and usually
we send the patrols off
from the adult campsite,
usually near the center of things.
I often cannot
see the patrols directly.
they're behind the palmettos, they're in a hammock,
they're, you know, they're
100 to
400 feet away.
they're not in the next county,
but you know they're off
on their own, they set up their own kitchen,
they cook their own meals.
they, you know they come through
during activity times.
but basically we adults just kind of
hang around the picnic table in the fire
circle
and it all happens kind of
around us out there.
and so
that seems to me
to be the modern version
of
what in the past was actually the patrol
and the patrol leader just
with their walking sticks heading out of town,
you know, to the little lake like follow me boys
or whatever. but
so,
being in the suburbs of Chicago,
it's a little hard for the boys to sort of set off on their own.
it's almost exactly what Larry was
saying. but after listening to
some of Clark's words of wisdom,
we took our,
the adults, took their campsite
and moved them
100 feet or so away
from the main campsite.
if we look hard
we can still see the blazing
campfire and we can sometimes
hear them. but
they are on their own
for the most part. they know where we are
and they were not that far away. but
I
we did that. this was the
the second time. this past weekend
was the second time we've been out there
and it seemed to
work pretty well again.
one of the lines in the
the guy who saves counting is
appropriate adult leadership
must be present for all overnight camping
activities. so the idea of
the boys hiking off a little distance
or some distance away from the adults
sort of brings up the question:
what is an appropriate distance
of
a good distance for appropriate adult leadership?
that's left
open because every
campsite is different and every troop is different.
you know, you kind of have to decide.
you know, there's in my troop,
for instance, 11 year old, brand
new weeblos.
I'm not going to send them off
the same place that the raven patrol goes
and those guys are 16
and 17 year old. they walk off
in the woods and go find a campsite
that's relatively
much further away.
we had a
backpacking trip last year.
I would say the older scouts were probably
almost a quarter of a mile away
in another campsite,
but close enough for emergencies
and close enough to
you know one or two adults.
you know, like one of the scouts,
dads walk by and say hi
and you know whatever.
it wasn't so far away that it was
a trek.
so you know, I think it's open.
that way
we've got
like a 15. we're on
the campsites on a lake
with about a 15 foot
drop off to the lake,
so we keep all the guys
together.
they're separated but together
so the older ones can keep an eye on the younger ones.
and
your question puts me in mind of
basically that sweet 16
of scout safety
and if people aren't familiar with that,
I think it's a really good test
for anything that we do.
if you look at that and you're
able to
conduct an activity
with just considerations,
then you're in good shape.
so that can be.
and, Larry, I think you
hit it spot on with
you're talking about
like the younger patrol versus the older patrol,
reminded me of ability groups
and the safe swim defense
or in safety afloat,
and you know.
so you're going to have to gauge
what the ability of a given patrol
is,
gauge what
your level of comfort
is with a given patrol
being, you know, out of sight,
Walter, did we hit most of the things that you
had hoped we would talk about so far
in the context of this? absolutely,
it's again. we've got
a relatively young
troop.
my son now is the oldest.
he's 16.
let him into the committee chair, son.
they're both 16, so they're less
involved as they used to be.
the next set of
kids are 14, the next oldest
and then all the way down we got four new we blows
coming over in a couple of weeks.
so we've got a relatively
inexperienced group. like I said,
the adult leadership has pretty much been running
the show, buying the groceries, cooking the food.
well, what's your,
what's your plan in May? the plan
in May is we've got
two training camps
scheduled.
basically, get the boys sort of organized.
I'm fighting
the I'm not fighting. I'm sort of
debating on on whether to
take one of your advice,
your bullet, your
podcasts, about
having the boys organize themselves into
patrols based on their own
desires, because there's a
we have patrols on paper
but no one can point to a
patrol leader.
so I'm thinking that that
would probably be one of the first things to do
when we get a critical
mass of the boys showing up.
how many friends,
I'm sorry, you said how many. how many
scouts are in the troop?
we've got about 18 on paper
and anywhere from anywhere from
8 to 12 show up at a given time.
so we've got the two
training camps, then summer camp
in the end, middle of
middle of July and then
we're off until August,
which we have a traditional we blows
invitation. we invite the we blows around
the neighborhood to come to a weekend.
I had some good feedback
from blaze vitally,
who was on the scout master panel
discussion. he he took one suggestion
which was
he has a smaller troop. he has,
I think, 8 or 12. I
suggested that they take the scout handbook
and turn to
the part that talks about patrols
and
just read that
and then say what happens
next. well, he did that and he said it worked.
well, that's in my notes to do. I've got
quite a few notes from your
podcasts.
I've got a 35 minute train ride
each way every day,
which is more than enough time
to listen to a podcast
and take notes, and
listen to it on the way home and take notes again
and
cross reference them.
do you have an annual planning conference?
yes, sir, we, yes,
yes, we do. we have them in August
for this way. we had our real
one this last year, which was
the boys ran it absolutely
and you could see some of the adults
just sort of edged, edgedy
and fidgety.
take them out,
yeah, yeah, and they did a phenomenal job.
good,
yeah, that's
vital. we do ours in May
and present it to the committee so we're ready
in August to kick off the year.
but, yeah, put them in the room
and close the door and let it go.
yeah, you mentioned that before in one of the
Costco master roundtables and
that's what I'm leaning toward now so the committee
can sort of look at it
and then finish it up, because it took
the committee four and a half months to get through
the calendar
after the boys did it. yeah, well,
you know how adults are.
that should be about five minutes where they,
the boys, present it,
they approve it and
boy, four months, that's
well, they're there. you know it's
adults, they're trying again.
I got to understand something.
the adults in the committee are
relatively new to one to
three years in the troop. they're all
Cub Scout leaders or were
okay. so there's
your mindset. okay, you got some more.
I do, I have some work
and I'm going to,
like some great wise men
once told me an email: take it slow
and easy and don't lose any sleep.
yeah, you do your best.
Tom's Council
has got a new Cub
leader deprogramming camp
that they're
going to set up, and
well, that's pretty much
what I'm trying to get my training
camps to be. it's pretty much deprogramming
the adults and then
let the boys deal with the younger boys.
it's, it's, it's. we've done it
last year and it worked out pretty nicely.
Scott master wasn't too happy with it,
but he didn't say much.
yeah, if you keep the adults
out of their hair, you will,
it will work.
and my lack of hair doesn't
let, doesn't that things cut right through.
yeah, right, Clark.
yes, yes, I am,
I am.
we are in possession of perfect
skulls. yes, exactly
why would one want to cover that with hair,
goodness Christ.
so since you're going to be a new scout
master- I'm not exactly sure where it was-
I just want to mention this tonight.
there was a comment by Rick H
yesterday
about trustworthy
and
you read that. Walter
and the other guys read that.
yes, it was
on this. it was one of the last two or
three
posts that he commented on about.
it was the one I wrote about
the heart of the scout
law. but then he talked about
trustworthy and he was talking about
putting the
scouts. he was just saying that
he doesn't do this, doesn't keep a list,
doesn't do that. he asked the scouts,
you know, and a scout is trustworthy
and he runs his troop based
on the scouts. word
and boy. that was.
I thought that was a powerful comment.
that's
that's a very important
aspect of it and
it is.
this is a battleship kind of a turn,
you know, or an aircraft carrier
kind of a turn. it takes a while.
yeah, oh yeah.
if you can get to that point,
I mean that's just great.
that's what I've been listening and learning
with the podcast is to
take it slow and don't
don't let the adults-
what I'm hearing is they don't give it
two months- to say, oh, we tried, we're done.
how long did it take, Tom?
I'm at a year now.
how long have you been at it?
18 wonderful years.
yes, I listen to the podcast,
Walter. did we cover everything we
needed to cover for you?
absolutely, you, gentlemen. I appreciate
your time and your effort
and your service
that these provide.
again, I listen quite often
and I've gained a lot of
patience. I think,
oh well, good,
I'm glad it's been useful, for you
need to have him back in a few months, Clark.
yes, we'll see.
give us a report. congratulations on that
promotion. thank you,
I got a bigger check too. they added one more zero
to my check.
unfortunately, the decimal point
moved three to the left,
but tell us
so. Walter Torres up in Chicago
really appreciate you being part of the
podcast tonight and
wish you the best of luck and your new role
as a scout master next month.
well, hey, Clark, thanks for the invitation.
it was a real gas to
to participate
and, like someone else said, I can't
wait to listen to the podcast.
Larry, keep it real down there now.
thanks, Clark, Tom,
I want to hear more about this new
facility that's being built down there.
I will tell you a lot about it
next April 1st.
what was that? April Fool's Joke? you played on us
it was.
it was some new property that our
council has purchased
and a lot of different
activities that they're going to be able to
to do, like
a whitewater rafting,
class 5
rapids
base, jumping off of some of the mountains
and three wheeling on some of the cliffs.
they're going to keep them off the roads,
but they're going to put them near the cliffs
with a base jumping, with a landing
zone lined in
or fenced in with barbed wire to keep people
from getting hit correct.
well, that's just smart. yeah, I thought so.
I know Larry didn't fall for any of that.
Tom, this is something you do and you
distribute to the district.
yes,
certain people that don't get
to
that won't fall for it too much,
but won't get too excited
about it.
oh my,
thank you once again
for listening to the scoutmaster podcast. let me
tell you how to keep in touch.
first of all, you can read the scoutmaster
blog at scoutmastercgcom
and there you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating.
and, as you heard earlier in the show,
if you own a zoom, if you're one of those
two or three dozen people who still own a zoom,
you might be able to find us on zoom marketplace by now.
you can also access the podcast
on your mobile device.
hey, don't get mad at me. if you own a zoom,
I'm just having a little fun at your expense.
that's what it's all about.
you can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through stitcher smart radio,
and you can get details about that
at stitchercom.
you can call and leave a voicemail, comment
or question at 484-734-0002
and you can experience
all the wonders of scoutmastercgcom-
and they are considerable-
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
you can follow us at
scoutmaster blog on facebook,
tweet scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
search for scoutmastercg
on google plus.
if you're not attracted to social media outlets,
if you don't like them,
if you don't face, if you don't tweet,
if you don't plus, hey, just email me.
that's right.
zoom into the late 90s
and send me an email
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
that's, scoutmastercg
all that remains for me to say
is: the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me with a microphone and a few friends
trying to help scoutleaders
and have a little bit of fun running around.
before we leave you, we'll hear from our founder,
Sir Robert David Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
well, thank you, sir.
until next time
we'll see you.